welcome to the house committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
we have several things to consider this
morning retained bills bills that have
been amended house bills that have been
amended by the Senate and later on this
morning we'll be going into executive
session but before we do any of that I'd
like to please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance
foreign
thank you
okay
uh yesterday morning
um I um had been looking through all of
my emails we had talked about the
retained bills I sent out a list of the
retained bills to all of the committee
members hopefully everyone received it
and um uh you know I it also indicated
uh everybody who has expressed an
interest in certain bills to date uh I
apologize I didn't have a chance to
update this after I sent it out I
received a few emails after this got
sent out yesterday morning I know
representative Leon had sent me an email
I didn't have a chance to put her
information on here or representative
I think they may have been one of two
others
so anyway uh basically what I'm hoping
to do this morning
is go through the various bills I put
down the people who have expressed
interest so far and particular bills
working on them as we know we have until
I think it's November
anybody know the date the final date uh
we haven't well deep into the fall
anyway before we have to resolve them uh
and uh it's my understanding in July and
August we really can't uh meet oh if we
do uh we uh it's going to be sanctioned
um and that they they discourage uh
summertime meetings but we do have a
little bit of time in June uh for some
of the most
I'm sorry 17 November 17th I think
that's the anniversary of the Bolshevik
Revolution or something but uh anyway
um
I remember my history but um uh you know
some of the simpler bills we might be
able to work on in June but many of
these are going to take certainly well
into the fall to complete
um so anyway uh with that I'll uh I'll
open it for discussion any thoughts on
uh and and actually before we get too
far I'd like to update names in terms of
um who wants to work on what because
again some of those emails I did not
put on here representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman
um there was an email from
representative
uh she is interested in 317.
if you want to write these down
uh 368
378 and then there are three that are
not on your list
um
well 580 is on the back oh is it oh okay
no wonder I couldn't find it 580 619
and
um 236
okay let me just repeat those back what
I may uh 2017 368 378
580 619 and 236. yes okay thank you and
if I may just I've said this to you but
I'll just state it for the committee I
think that there are several sets of
bills that could possibly be referred to
one particular subcommittee and the one
I'm thinking of in particular are House
Bill 264
um house bill 368.
and the opposite of 368 which is
uh the bill that for since 19619 those
three I thought it it particularly
because two bills are on the same
subject and take an opposite Viewpoint
it would be unfortunate if we referred
them to a two different subcommittees
who came to opposite conclusions sure it
would be helpful if we had at least
one set of
eyes looking at it for the first part
and if there's division at the end of it
of course that's
perfectly all right we do that all the
time sure thank you thank you
representative Leon I know you had sent
me an email too I do want to share your
thoughts um yes thank you um I'm
interested in participating on the
transgender issued ones which would be
317 368 and 619.
317 368
okay and 6 19.
okay
um
also on the developmental disability
ones which are first one was
317.
sorry I'm sorry I I said that one
already 264 I was on the birth record so
I apologize I'm giving you the wrong
number you want to be on 364.
64 I'm sorry yeah um and then also 608
for a developmental disabilities
okay and also on the sexual assault um
which is 378.
sure
oh yes yes representative profile
thank you Mr chairman um I had sent an
email uh yesterday
looking to be added for 317
um and then I also wanted to put my name
in for 608
and then I have a strong interest in 406
and I think that's something that we
should be
talking to the chair of children and
family law about and uh it actually
happens to be here he is here today
I was here to be alone the Alum
Association
okay representative I could just repeat
those
um
406 you just mentioned
um 317
580 and 608 correct okay
any other names to be added
representative Murphy thank you
um I would like to participate as
possible on House Bill 329
and also house bill 580.
okay 329 and 580.
okay and the others
I had requested HP 566
okay
hi representative McLean oh I think 329
is important and it's looking pretty
light so I'll go up on that one as well
okay
which one
sorry 329
I'm also interested in 317 but I think
he got enough staff on that one
okay
anyone else
any other representative mazura
yes if you could add me to 368 and 619
with some of my colleagues that'd be
great
okay 368 and what was the other one 6 19
368 and 619 okay
okay any others
representative McKay yeah
any others
there now
where we have two uh former chairman
here you can advise me is there a limit
to how big a subcommittee can be
no and and as you and I discussed
earlier
um
subcommittees are supposed to be
composed in the same
makeup as the general makeup of the
house generally speaking that's a
protection for the minority and I have
seen in the past where sometimes by
agreement people have departed from that
and if everybody's in agreement with it
I'm not going to make any fuss about it
but as you recognize there are certain
ones that are
political hot potatoes where it will be
best if we stick to the sure
ladder of the rule
we need to sift through here and
um
and if I may I mean there's no need for
you to actually give us a final decision
today okay all right
all right I appreciate that yeah we'll
also through these and again I
representative Weber you suggested that
we have 264 368 and 619 is one
subcommittee are there any other
groupings here that anybody would
recommend be another subcommittee
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman I'd recommend the developmental
disabilities bills which is our 317 and
608 to be together
yep
that was the other set but I was
thinking about
everything for something
okay which two of those please
317 and 608.
and again these would be as a formal
subcommittee by both of these
yes I think that would be good right
okay
any other formal subcommittees that we
need the alternative being of course
more of an informal Discussion Group
um representative whoever if you name a
group it becomes a subcommittee of this
house so uh we may decide that we don't
want a formal subcommittee in which case
people are going to have to get together
on their own otherwise we're going to do
these issues right
foreign
I would like to be added to uh 608
because that is something also being
explored by the
oversight Committee of DHHS thank you
okay
any others
okay any other bills here that would
lend themselves to uh any kind of formal
subcommittee that you can see
anybody thinks representative Leon thank
you Mr chairman um I believe that the
sexual assault one may make sense to
have a subcommittee so that we can hear
from those Prosecuting attorneys and
everybody else who has a stake into
whether or not these people should be
offered these kits down about 378 uh yes
378.
and um
I think it's quite possible that the
organ donation one as well makes sense
587 since there's been some big changes
with the Uno's system to get a better
understanding of where New Hampshire
moves as the Nationals landscape is
looking a bit different
again you're recommending a formal
subcommittee right and
just to make your life either easier or
harder as the case may be I would
recommend that we had formal
subcommittees on all of this you have
people who have interests in all of the
bills
um and it really does for some of them
it may only need one meeting
but I think it makes good sense when we
have a lot of time and the ability to
schedule meetings
to have the formal subcommittee process
it's something that we did a lot more of
in the pre-covered days and have gotten
away from but I think it really comes
out with a better result and either it
forges a consensus or it makes very
clear what the competing interests are
and it makes it easier for the full
committee to have and then the house to
have real confidence in the process and
that the people who wanted to be
included as stakeholders
have had their opportunity to be
included as stakeholders and and you
know they may or may not choose to take
up that offer but I think it's a better
process okay so that's my suggestion
okay
so we have 14 bills three five six seven
of them are addressed so far
as far as subcommittees any other
groupings that anyone would suggest that
lend themselves to a formal subcommittee
I think the others could have something
that he's put these standalones
is that unwieldy to have that many
again I'm just asking the question I I'm
not challenging the idea I'm just asking
I think it I think it depends on how
willing people are to work on them
um but as far as I can see the work
needs to get done whether it's in a
formal subcommittee or whether it's
informally
and I think the work ought to be done
formally if at all possible Mr chairman
in my first two terms in this committee
that's what we did and that doesn't mean
this committee has to it just means we
found that useful okay
all right again that's something I'm not
as familiar with representative
representative Shapiro and then
representative Weber
I'm just wondering about House Bill 566
which is relative to establishing fund
for child care in early childhood
Educators and it seems to me like that
might have been
unusual that it came here as opposed to
coming to education in the first place
and
um I'm wondering
if we're going to continue with it and
have a retained Bill committee
is it possible to overlap with the
education committee because it seems
like if another bill was created out of
this retained bill that it would
very likely go to the education
committee and not to us children and
family or children and family
representative Pearson for this special
committee on this very subject Chair by
representative rossbury right
I'm about to get some advice on this
matter
right that's that's a better idea
once we've had here and she'll suffering
well yeah but I mean
the education deals what they do not do
early check but they don't
okay
education does not deal with Early
Childhood issues so
right or a special committee on Child
Care yeah
earlier in the process representative
Weber and representative and I tried to
process out some of these bills to other
committees and we were not successful we
were told careful consideration had been
made in the assignments and they were
hours and I can't remember if this was
one of them or not but it was it was
okay
representative thank you actually in
that vein one of the bills that's been
noticed on our calendar 527 had been
vacated to finance so that's why it's
not on our allocation list if anybody
has been comparing those two so it's
noticed for us here but that's a finance
bill
okay
all right so I will um
oh yes yes thank you sir Mr chairman uh
even if you can't get rid of the Early
Childhood bill you could certainly uh as
you know bring in that subcommittee as
consultants to update U.S to their
thinking
okay yeah that's that's true
representative Weber
we also have in in the somewhat more
distant past there was a tradition of
when a bill was assigned to a particular
committee but it particularly pertained
to two different committees
and I'm thinking of one that was
administrative adjudications in the
Department of Environmental Services
we have had a member of the other
Committee just sit in to advise they
don't get a vote they're not an official
member but you could certainly you would
certainly be within your rights I think
to ask if somebody from either of the
other committees and and certainly there
are people who are on both might come
and help aid with the deliberations
representative Pearson are you on
representative Aries committee as an
adjunct member yes okay but we do have
somebody who's on the committee
um as a regular full participant member
who's also on children and family law is
that representative Nelson don't ask
oh okay
well I'm thinking Bill Nelson yes my
external memory stick says you're right
okay all right
representative Simone is on both also
okay
okay good to know
two
representative Shapiro I don't know if
there is a final disposition on this I
it's an area that I have a lot of
interest in but I'm hesitant to
participate in a you know a subcommittee
if it's really belongs someplace else
and it's going to be acted on someplace
else
um
we've already had hearings on it and
everything else yeah okay we we it's my
understanding once you start having
hearings and taking do you know taking
it up in committee you stuck with it
that's why you know again a few of us
try to get rid of some of these things
early on and
not successful so get on it okay I'll
then I would
um express interest in that committee as
well 566 yeah okay
okay
yes
representative Cannon
okay
any other thoughts or interests
and again
um yeah I will swap these through and
come up with some suggestions and um
formal appointments of chairman and vice
chairman of the subcommittees and you
know we can sift through that in the
days to come and again we want we want
to balance all of these out and not only
because we have to but because you know
we should if we're going to come up with
meaningful conclusions and
recommendations for the full committee
that 566 looks like so
if it is going to go forward and I
thought maybe it went with just with
just representative Cushman but if it's
now the compliments filling up I'd like
to be on that as well okay all right
representative King also
oh yeah
representative King had mentioned
earlier he'd like to be on it
anyone else on this uh bill or any
others
okay
all right well it's a work in progress
but thank you for all of the input I
appreciate that and I'll uh I'll get
back to you at least via email and um
and then obviously we'll be meeting
again anyway
um
Ms Dyer has given us
side by side so
Senate action on a couple of our bills
and the purpose here is uh
representative Weber had suggested if I
remember correctly maybe a straw poll in
terms of what we should do going forward
um in terms of conferring non-concurring
representative Shapiro can I just go
back to the previous conversation sorry
um I would just I don't know what other
people's interest or lack of interest in
this but I I was just thinking if for
those of us who live further away if we
could kind of overlap some of the
scheduling of these subcommittees
um
that some overlap on similar days so
those of us who are on two three four
committees might be able to come to
concrete walks I mean I'm going to defer
to subcommittee membership and
leadership in terms of when you want to
meet
you know you know I it's it's impossible
for me to know exactly what's going to
work out for all of you so uh you know
by all means I'd encourage you all to
work together and you know with your
respect to members to figure that out
but that makes absolute sense because I
know
we'd like to think it's a small state
but sometimes it doesn't feel like it is
there you go exactly exactly
we don't want to overwork those kiosks
in the lobby you know
okay anything else on the retained
Wheels
okay great thank you
again getting back to the two Senate
bills a third one was just amended
um fairly innocuous changes but that one
we we don't have this morning but
um post Bill 238 and House Bill 408 the
changes are indicated here side by side
um these have been previously sent out
in an email
and um
just wanted to get reaction uh
ultimately we'll have to make a
recommendation I would imagine on June
8th Miss Dyer
um we would need to make a
recommendation of concurring
non-concurring at that point
uh to the full house so and at some
point I think we need to take a formal
vote in this committee but I don't
believe we can do it this morning
because it was not noticed as such but
uh representative Weber we've never
noticed these oh ever okay
um and I don't know what the rationale
for that is we we do as a house often
ignore the right to know law but which
is not a great way to do it but before
we take a funnel vote on these we should
notice them in the calendar I would
assume no we we've never noticed
anything having to do with these and
various speakers have taken various
positions from uh on the one hand you
will have a meeting with your committee
and even if it's you know calling people
up and and getting a vote from each
person
and follow that vote to the chair will
make the decision and won't talk to
anybody on the committee about it at all
so I very much appreciate your including
everybody but they have often been very
informal you know Gatherings Under the
Clock in the in the hall or things like
that
okay and I I think maybe the rationale
for it is that it's the bill is no
longer in the hands of the committee the
bill is in the hands of the house
and we're not a quorum of the house so
in that respect it may just fall
completely outside the right to no law
entirely
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I had actually inquired of the
clerk as to that question and yes it's
uh not a quorum because so this is now
in the hands of the Full House and while
I think we're an important 20 members
we're only 20 or 400.
five percent right
okay well any any reactions uh to 238
let's just take them in order
um
any any thoughts
any
oh yes representative Shapiro
um if I'm understanding this correctly
and I I would uh appreciate being
corrected if I'm not it seems to me that
um the Senate amend amendments amend the
parts that are amended do two things one
is that they remove
you're talking about 238 now 38. so
we had amended the part about
Contracting with contractors
um and um made it a little bit gave the
the quality Council a little bit less
power in that because we thought that
was a conflict but the Senate has taken
that out completely I believe
um so that's one change
so that there's no mention of the
um Quality
control Council being involved in the
Contracting process at all it doesn't
mean they can't be but it's not like
um required from this bill so that's one
thing the other thing is that just in
general from some of the small changes
it seems to put more of the
responsibility on the council making
recommendations versus
DHHS
requesting recommendations and um
for example on page there's no page
numbers but the fifth page
um
number eight on the house version
it talks about the department reaching
out to the Quality Council about about
the possibility of changes and I believe
that that seems to be removed from the
Senate version
so it it kind of um requires more
initiative on the part of the the
quality Council versus the um Department
so those are the two changes I I see
um I know some people who came to
testify won't be happy with the part
that removes the part about Contracting
um
so I don't know what that means in terms
of what I think
um I still think it's still a good bill
um
mature thoughts uh concur not concur
media conference uh
I'm not really I'm kind of up in the air
but
um I would hate to see the bill get
killed in the long run because I think
it still has value but um
maybe it could be better by sending it
to a committee of conference I I would
defer to other people's ideas before I
make my decision representative Pearson
thank you Mr chairman uh when I first
ran for the house a number of years ago
the developmental disability issue was
one I decided to uh work on a lot
because of uh patients at my medical
center
um our DD folks some of them and then
when I became chairman of DHHS oversight
three years ago I would be present when
the whole DD question would be coming up
again and again and while I believe the
people at DHHS who work on this very
issue are good people and motivated and
so on I believe the more encouragement
from the quality Council the better for
their doing their work so
just another way of saying I'm sorry the
last part of this was left out by the
Senate
other other comments uh representative
Leon uh thank you Mr chairman
um I think that when we look at this we
also need to understand that the world
for the developmental disability
Community is in a lot of flux right now
they're changing some of the allowances
on the federal level we're changing the
way we do things here I think that even
if in the future we were to back off of
some of these requirements I think that
right now this more of a two-way
conversation is important so I think
that we probably need further work on
this to figure out where we can meet
with the Senate to make sure that people
are heard but it's not too much of an
illness
so I would go for a committee of
conference
other comments representative McLean
yeah thank you Mr chair
um I basically agree with everything
that's been said I I would vote to to
non-concur I think none of these things
at the Quality Council
none of these things is binding but what
it's doing is it's forcing the
discussion and it's if there may be
things that might slip past them or
whatever in terms of contracts so it's
actively bringing them into the
discussion and as I said none of it is
binding so
um absence some concrete understanding
of why the Senate took it out I I can't
believe because his two burdensome would
be enough I think we should non-concur
and and have that discussion thank you
okay thank you
other comments of Representative Weber
I agree
um I I will make the comment that
tactically Bizzle is a risk with a
committee of conference
um and I have in the past occasionally
seen a really good bill
vanish because somebody on one side or
the other got cranky about it what has
traditionally happened in the house is
when somebody has said I'm not going to
go along with what maybe the majority of
the two different subcommittees wants
the house Speaker has been very active
about removing that person and replacing
them with somebody who is shall we say
more amenable
I have also seen a time when
one member from the Senate was put on a
committee of conference for the sole
purpose of not concurring and making
sure that a bill died and they were not
replaced because that was their purpose
and altogether I cannot think why that
would happen with this bill because we
are very close and it's it's a matter
that I think all of us are very
concerned about and the question is just
how best to address the issues so I
think there's less likelihood that some
things that the wheels are going to come
off but I I just want to make sure that
those who have not lived with this
process before know that there are all
kinds of strange things that can happen
in the committee of conference process
but that being said I too think a
committee of conference would be
advisable on this one because
um as we know there's not only this bill
but there have been any number of other
bills
that have come before us about people
who don't feel like they've been
consulted properly and I think that
anytime we can encourage
the people that our laws affect the
lives of to have their input considered
um you know we're we're more likely to
make better decisions for one thing and
if they disagree with the final decision
they will be more willing to accept it
because they know that their voices have
been heard and listened to even if the
answer is no
anyone who does not agree with the
discussion anybody who thinks that we
should do the non-concare period or
um open current
everything seems to suggest that we want
to non-concur and ask for a committee of
conference is that pretty much the
sentiment representative Shapiro I will
I will agree with people who've
expressed that view very eloquently
okay great
all right saying no dissent on that then
that would be the recommendation I would
make to the Full House at the June 8th
session
moving on to House Bill 408
um a little more straightforward
only one page at least
so
any comments about that
representative profile
yes thank you Mr chairman so this the
the Senate amendment was actually the
product of a a very collaborative
process between myself
um the policy director over the Senate
and
um Mr Williams and Abby Rogers from uh
from DHHS we came up with language that
I think
satisfied the concerns that
dcyf had with regard to Foster family
homes and and potential funding issues
we actually simplified the language I
think with respect to the protections
for children living in foster homes and
and we added a provision that DHHS will
submit a waiver request to the federal
government
to essentially
um
you know to to to validate the the
assertion that
children in foster homes will have the
same rights to exemptions as
as anybody else in the state so
um my my request is that we do a simple
concur with this and uh and move this
one forward
that had been your bill originally right
correct yes I'm the prime sponsor okay
and the discussion on 408
that is that we concur as as it's been
submitted here representative Weber
I think I think that you know the idea
of a waiver of the federal mandate is a
is a good one and either we will get a
waiver or we'll not get a waiver but in
the absence of a waiver it is possible I
think that we would have problems uh
I I would I would agree with a motion to
concur
the discussion on 408.
seeing none we will I will recommend to
the house that we concur
okay unless some yes representative
Weber
would you care to let us know what the
other one that's been amended that
you've referred to so that we can House
Bill 611 perhaps have a quick discussion
on that as well sure sure it just
happened last uh Thursday I don't have a
we don't have the copy I'm sorry
you don't have that right yeah I mean
I'm sorry oh that'd be great if you
could okay thank you we might as well
sure
um Alicia uh Preston actually called me
about this yesterday and I wasn't sure
if we'd get to it this morning uh but if
on the event
we did I I did tell her I'd mention our
comments now one of the things it does I
from what again I I don't have the in
front of me obviously but could you tell
us the book bill number uh six eleven
six one one
and it's one of my my understanding at
least in part perhaps completely it
basically substitutes one commission
with another it's about studying
cannabis and its future it's I guess
it's legalization uh in concert with a
lot of the other discussions that have
been held in recent days
um
Alicia Preston had called me because she
represents clients who really understand
growing it and and
the whole the whole nature of the
product and this commission does not
allow for anybody who has actually has
that insight and experience to be on the
commission
and she said you know if it's going to
be a commission there should be somebody
who's familiar with rowing it and and
using it uh and uh for the most part
that's not the case and again we'll see
that in a moment so that was her main
purpose in contacting me and whenever we
had this discussion she she asked that I
bring it up so
so anyway
it's about all I know at the moment
right
representative Weber
so just as I'm looking at the analysis
um it um
they have the bill is we passed it
simply uh removed the requirements
severe pain be resistant to other
treatment options as a precursor to
being able to
use therapeutic therapeutic cannabis and
I haven't checked but I assume those are
relatively similar
the two other things it adds is it adds
a commission to study State controlled
sales of cannabis and it also prohibits
the sale of hemp products containing
certain amounts of THC
my understanding is that
um one of the issues with CBD products
is that many of them are not monitors as
carefully as they might be so that
people wind up ingesting more THC than
they thought they were ingesting and
they have a right to know
but I haven't I haven't read through
that second part so I don't know exactly
what the focus is
I wonder if because we have a lot of
moving parts
with respect to therapeutic cannabis and
who is going to be studying what
um whether this is one that's either
better held to the last date for forming
Committees of conference or whether we
ought to request a committee of
conference solely to keep everybody's
options open and and communicate to the
Senate that that's why we're doing it
but so that we can actually I mean we
don't have to do anything right now and
I would I would vote for leaving it
until we've had another chance to
discuss but
I know that there are several bills to
which study committees have either
already
been established or or have been
attached so we might want to just put
this on for committee of conference just
so that
we have a better idea which of the many
options is going to be the best one
the commission that they're adding we
just finished a very expensive there's
been a lot of work done and just
recently it's worth looking at and I
think provision three was to build what
we heard that came through committee
maybe last year last session I just
haven't had a chance to look into it so
I can certainly provide pronunciation
but this is why have a great day thank
you
okay I have a discussion on this
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman uh looking at it briefly
looking at the Amendments that the
Senate put in they leave the initial two
sections that that we have passed about
allowing allowing these patients to get
the care they need but they added
essentially a commission to study what
the what the governor had put forth is
his solution after the Senate shot down
the house supported position on
legalization
um and that's a matter of whether or not
that study would be a useful study or
not that's that's one question and then
the other is around these
basically what you go into a gas station
you see and it says it has THC even
though it's not the regulated one so it
is rather complex
um I I think it's uh kind of a shame
that all of this has been added on when
all we're trying to do is get
appropriate care to patients and um I
think that there would have been a
better Avenue for them to to address
their concerns as opposed to putting it
here so I'm a little disappointed
representative Shapiro
yeah Piggyback in on representative Leon
it seems a little bit odd that the the
underlying Bill deals with therapeutic
cannabis and then they've added
something to
um deal with
um adult use of cannabis recreational
use
um and I I don't really know so
um it makes it sound like this will be
the one vehicle to kind of study the
issue when I know that it's been studied
endlessly and are there any other
current commissions or study committees
that this commission overlaps with I
don't really know the answer to that but
I don't know if anybody does and this is
working on that right now right in terms
of further research I believe that
representative
um oh my gosh he did not return
um
representative Egan no
um so it's abrami excuse me they just
finished a commission on cannabis last
year and this would repeal the existing
commission and re-study some of it I
also believe that there was a bill that
came to the Health and Human Services
last year tour 2021 about the hemp
um provision but I can look more into
that that'd be great thank you
representative Weber
the more I listen to this the more I
think I would suggest that we just
non-concurrent ask for committee of
conference right up front so that we can
discuss some of these issues and we
certainly will have some time to do the
research on
it sounds to me very much like there may
be an existing commission that can
actually just take this over
um and and but
um I would be loath to just
concur without further discussion
and I also would be loathed to just let
the bill die because I think the two
sections that we send over uh were good
and useful policy that we all agreed on
and I too am
sorry that it has other stuff added on
to it but that's the hand we've been
dealt so I think that maybe going and
talking to the senate about it is
probably the best the best way to deal
with it representative
I'm probably in minority but I would
recommend concurring uh with this
version it still helps the patients and
does what we wanted to do just add some
studying of safety effects so personally
I recommend concurring you recommend
concurrent concern
representative Pearson thank you Mr
chairman
um correct me but I thought we passed a
bill that said if we're going to have a
commission 51 percent of the members
have to be legislated to us and
um I'd have to do what three or four
counts to see if that's true here but
having said that I've never seen five
Senators show up for anything except you
know their their meetings
um but they drafted it
denial is not just a river in Egypt uh
so I just wondered uh if if this is
actually correctly drawn up it's exactly
even exactly even okay thank you I would
draw that then but still the question of
getting a quorum with so many senators
being named is a bit problematic to me
having shared these things and not seen
Senators show up
well representative Glover the the
Senate is still only 25 of the
commission so
um even if all the Senators don't show
up we have an opportunity for four other
members also to be absent
um representative Merchant but I'm not
sure that the commission is worth doing
given the amount of time and energy
that's been spent on this and the fact
that we had a bill last year
that was quite similar to this
and at the time the governor was not at
all receptive
um nor was the Senate so
one wonders why we bothered to study
them again and again and again
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair
I would say to nanker
um possibly committing a conference and
my rationale is that this is really kind
of
not
dealing with the law exam between the
house and the Senate I would much prefer
to have a study committee comprise the
people that are going to look at this
and get some sort of concurrence between
the house and the Senate on a version of
a bill we all can live with and
ultimately pass next year
creating this Commission in a lot of
ways doesn't resolve that and I'm really
concerned that there are underlying
issues that need to be addressed by the
house and the Senate and that seems to
be where the Log Jam is I would prefer
to have a study committee comprised of
both Chambers in order to come up with
something that both Chambers can support
thank you representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman that law that we passed
limits the the number of people on the
commission to 15 with the majority of
lawmakers so those numbers would not
work
um
I I do like the idea that if we were
going to have something to discuss this
we perhaps would in committee a
conference look to a study committee
with an appropriate makeup and invite
the attorney general and the governor to
come help with us as well and see where
we can get agreement
um but looking also to um
the larger picture there actually is
also a non-germain amendment that was
heard yesterday in Commerce in order to
try and uh Circle the square on cannabis
so there may be maybe a solution that
may come through this year or at least
that gives us another jumping off point
to move closer to that agreement so I do
like this idea potentially having a
position of a study committee so that we
can actually find an answer find a
solution with this legislature this
Governor this attorney general and
finally get something done on this for
the people in New Hampshire
representative McLean yeah thank you I
mean I I agree with the non-concurrence
we sent over a clean bill and I I like
the the committee model I mean another
thing about the Commission in many
respects the commission presupposes the
outcome of being a state-controlled
model which may very well be the way to
go but if you're going to have a study
commission
um you know I don't want to put the car
before the horse and say this is what
the outcome is going to be so um for all
those reasons I think it's wise to not
concur
okay
another discussion
all right I'm hearing the general
consensus be none Concur and ask for
committee of conference is that correct
Mr chairman hand uh
representative thank you Mr chairman so
just just a a point of information
because there's been a couple of
comments or questions about the the
composition of the committee
um the language in the Senate version
begins with the phrase or section two of
section you know part two of section
three notwithstanding RSA 1449 so this
is something we're running up again
seeing the committee on commissions is
uh this magic phrase notwithstanding RSA
1449 essentially says you know the
following is not going to conform to to
the the statute as it is and those those
uh the statute regarding
compositional commissions as it is so
just point of information
okay
another discussion
okay and again basically the what I'm
hearing is non-concur with a committee
of conference is other than
representative does anyone else have a
concerned about that
not that we don't appreciate you I will
turn into the majority okay all right
thank you
all right that'll be what I recommend to
the house then representative thank you
Mr chairman um I've done a search to
find we actually have one other that's
been returned but I don't know if we've
officially received it yet but House
Bill 642 on the budget flexibility for
development disabled we're gonna have to
take more of a look at it but I just
wanted to let everybody know that that
one's been returned with an amendment
yeah I had not heard about that one I
just searched it now oh okay when did it
when did they amend it was it last week
um they amended it last week on the 11th
okay
um
all right that's that's all I know about
that
um any anything else for the work
session uh before we've got a couple of
minutes before we need to go into
executive session
all right let's we just asked for a
couple of minutes and then we'll return
thank you
I'd like to call us back to order uh we
are an executive session a little bit
late I apologize for that uh I'd like to
open up the discussion on
um Senate Bill 240 and representative
merchant do you wish to make a motion
make a motion to
pass Amendment two zero two three
one nine five four h well second and
representative lay on seconds
representative Merchant would you like
to speak to your motion yes it would
thank you chair
this bill came to us about a concern a
way that the data for genetic testing
and so forth could be utilized in the
clinical care of the patient if you look
at the statute the way it's written now
there is confusion So to avoid the use
of the data within the clinical care of
a patient this bill basically addresses
that secondly it also addresses the fact
that there's a specific consent by the
patient to release it
we had one last hanging issue which is
dealing with the use of de-identified
patient data for clinical research a lot
of that came down to is that many times
we have information within the system
but the system does not have
patient-specific information if you
identify it's hard to get the patient to
find out who you have to get the consent
from
so instead of trying to tackle all three
issues consent use of the data for
clinical for the patient care
the committee the subcommittee elected
to break it apart into two pieces one is
to take care of this one for this year
take care care of the patient which is
what we're trying to get to so the
patient can be taken care of and the
data can be shared amongst the men
members of the clinical team
number two the other issue about the
data itself
de-identified and so forth the
recommendation by the subcommittee to
this committee is to then
get our group together maybe over the
summer
ad hoc if you will and come back with
another bill next year to address that
issue so fundamentally this bill does
two fun two things one identifies
specifically patient consent
and it allows for
the clarifies if you will the use of the
data amongst the
clinical care team so the data can be
shared amongst providers of trying to
care for the patient
thank you representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman uh I may be
really thick but
are we saying that there was a there's a
currently in statute it says that
someone who has genetic testing that the
information can't be shared with their
medical providers even if they give
consent
I know that's not relevant to the this
amendment because this amendment is
trying to fix that but is that the case
representative Weber
we're certainly unclear enough I mean I
don't think it is the case I don't think
it should be the case but it was unclear
enough that one of the things that we
wanted to clarify with the amendment is
that the patient can consent to whatever
the patient wants to consent to the
issue came up with respect to I mean
we've always enacted statutes to be very
careful of people's genetic material and
the people it shared with so there was
concern that the statute that is now
written when you're looking for a
clinical trial that might be effective
for a particular patient and their
designs of them and there are
clearinghouses
um what the statute expressly permits is
submitting genetic material for those
studies
but it's ridiculous to subject you you
have the genetics analyzed once you can
send the data it was not entirely clear
that the data could be sent
um and and I think this just made all of
us a little on the subcommittee at least
a little more comfortable with
making sure that patients can consent to
whatever they want to consent to but
that their consent is required thank you
for that clarification
if you had a merchant then
representative Murph thank you Mr chair
where the confusion lies is in 141 H2 3.
and I'm going to paraphrase that no
person shall disclose to any other
person that an individual hasn't
undergone genetic testing and no
personal disclose the results of such
testing to any other person without
written
consent and that's where it got into the
gray area that representative Weber is
talking about we heard from people their
concern was it wasn't clear enough for
them to feel that they could actually
share the most political team that's
taking care of the patient so we wanted
to clarify
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman I
I appreciate separating these two out
and I I think that's the appropriate way
to go
um certainly the C refers to the
clinical research and you can understand
why I mean the clinical care of the
patient is different than the research
arm that would use the data for other
purposes perhaps and I think that's
important to separate them out section B
says that the the analysis and the
testing
um can be disclosed to entities that are
caring for the patient I can understand
that as well you may do a procedure here
but they don't have the the specific
protocol in in that institution but they
have to go somewhere else they have to
share that data so that's important to
me as well what I'm trying to my
question is I guess is
and again
I'm just trying to understand it because
I understand getting
parental consent parental patient
consent for you know procedures
um and what will happen when they have a
procedure done as a surgeon what I'm
trying to understand is what is referred
to as the consenting patient by a
Clinical Laboratory so
if you can explain to me I'm just trying
to understand what is the definition of
consenting of a consenting patient are
they consenting for the say a biopsy are
they consenting for a buckle smear are
they consenting for a laboratory study
only or are they consenting to doing a
procedure taking a test and then
in that same consent is that also
implied that they can use that data for
entities outside the provider where it
was taken to help in the treatment of
the patient is that I'm trying to our
our intent was
to allow for the broadest use once a
patient has consented to Broad use
to share it as widely as possible to
enable trials to be to come up
uh we didn't want to be too specific
about
how that worked uh in the discussions
that we had and I'll defer to the others
if they feel differently because this is
just my perception but uh the sticking
point for us was the addition of
de-identified
uh material being used for people doing
retrospective studies to find out
how effective a particular treatment had
been and the thing that we were
grappling with and simply felt we had no
time to do it successfully or
thoughtfully is the more you de-identify
data the less useful it is in terms of
uh
pinpointing which members of a
particular population may be more the
treatment may be more effective for so
or
pinpointing other issues that might
affect the results so
um we just didn't feel like we could
deal with that and that actually was a
piece that was
tacked onto the original bill which was
all about clinical treatment so
we did not grapple
with the absolute specifics of stuff
what we were really focusing on was
allowing a patient to consent
to whatever a patient wanted to consent
to because like representative Shapiro's
first question uh a lot of us sitting
here were really startled to find out
that a patient couldn't give effective
consent or that there was a concern
about patients giving effective consent
to certain things
so can I call it so if I could give a
concrete example and again I I agree
with this and I would like to have it go
forward and I I'm just trying to
understand consent so for instance if I
had a consent for a procedure it's
listed what would happen you know
potentially anything from a great
success to a death you know and anything
in between in people that would
participate in a procedure or not
um uh that sort of thing infection etc
etc so my question is
how do you protect or how do you assuage
those concerned about having a broad
stroke for consent when you deal with
the genetic testing or analysis that
says okay I'm trying to understand this
if I had a somebody in my family had a
bracket gene they said I just want to
know if I have that Gene but I don't
want that shared for protection of my
siblings and my children for insurance
purposes or otherwise how is that
assured that that information is not you
know widely dispersed to the point where
it could potentially harm or influence
the care of a sibling or family member
representative way I think oh I'm sorry
uh thank you Mr chairman um if you look
at the larger part of the 141-8 which is
about genetic testing we're talking
about just the conditions of genetic
testing section three is the use of
genetic testing and employment situation
section four is in health insurance and
section 5 is in life disability income
disability income and long-term care
insurance it prohibits that use for
anybody so that we don't get that
discrimination based upon your genetic
testing
um and part of this as well you're
talking about that overall consent
if you're coerced to do it if the only
way you can get the genetic testing is
to share your data now and forever
that's not consent that's acquiescence
and it's very different there are some
Cancer Centers where they pay for your
genetic testing and if you consent for
them to pay for it they're able to use
your data in the ways that they spell
out with the IRB so they're doing a lot
of great research there but they're also
fronting that money to pay for that
genetic research and with that exchange
it does make sense so we were just
trying to make sure that that genetic
retrospect that retrospective research
which is not clinical research because
it's not based upon the specific patient
but is more population based that that
has appropriate treatment because the
people who had come and testified wanted
to be able to to access this information
as broadly as possible because the more
data you use the better your conclusions
but the medical records belong to the
patient not to the institution and so
that balance is going to take a lot more
than we could do here we have the
pressing need that to match somebody to
a clinical trial or find another
provider that's offering especially for
a rare disease you can't just go through
the clinicaltrials.gov and try and
search for those it's just too
cumbersome so there's Clearing Houses
and that is the biggest part about
section B is to be able to disclose it
for the entities participating in the
clinical care which are those
clearinghouses that try and match these
patients with those promising treatments
especially because we're seeing such a
proliferation of treatments for these
rare diseases but nobody can say on top
of it I mean you have you have all the
different institutions you have it for
obstetrics and gynecologic cancers you
have ACOG then you have others so you
need to be able to reach out into all of
these and we need computers so and yes
representative Weber and then
representative McLean and and to ask
answer your specific question about
limiting the uses you can always limit
the uses as well I mean you're going to
have to read the form and say well gee I
don't want all of this or you're going
to have to tell your care provider look
I want to know this for myself I want to
be darn sure that my
siblings my Offspring don't get this and
and they're not allowed to share it
anyway I mean that's just basic you
can't share it with anybody who isn't
Under the Umbrella of what you've
already consented to so
um I I think patients
for I I will
I mean from the patient perspective and
also from the perspective somebody who
sat here and listened to patients a lot
they come in two varieties some people
go in and say sure I'll consent to
whatever you think I need to consent to
give me the forms and take them away
again and then you have patients who are
very very careful and thorough about
what they can send to because it's very
important to them and they won't sign
blanket consents they will put limits on
them but
our whole focus in the approach that we
adopted was to leave the control with
the patient
I can't I can't answer for instance
about they've done this and they've done
this I will say that we did have
involved in the negotiations there was a
clinician who uh from Dartmouth medical
who vetted the language
and helped us with the language so there
was a clinical perspective involved in
the process
representative McLean and then
representative Merchant yeah thank you
Miss Jaren I I sat in on one of the work
sessions just watched everybody so I
thought everybody did a really awesome
job the one question I have you know
kind of gets back to representative
Weber's comments about you know blanket
consent versus non-blankit consent
um and the nature of the consenting
patient so we see
um Gene testing it's really evolving so
let's just say for example at some point
in the future I'll just kind of role
play a little bit if I had rheumatoid
arthritis and and I'm so my treating
physician case is working with me and
maybe trying to develop treatments with
me so if at some point my treating
position decides I'd really like to have
Mark go in and have genetic testing done
because we have all these things with
rheumatoid arthritis and if if I just
really wasn't comfortable for whatever
reason with that kind of testing with
this language as it's written allow me
to say no that's something I I don't
want because it says on the C-section it
says specific informed consent so I'm
just kind of wondering how that kind of
would play out
representative Merchant and thank you Mr
chair and thank you Richmond McLean
also in the statute if you go back and
look at section two there's a line in
here it says no person shall refuse to
perform
genetic testing or to arrange for
genetic testing to be performed or do
business within with an individual
solely because the individual to be
tested refuses
refuses to consent
to provide tough results to any other
person
so if you don't want those results to go
anywhere else you have that right that's
why if you look at the way it's written
it allows for it only when it's
specified within the consent form so the
consent form is what's driving this if
the patient ultimately consents to it
whatever they consent to is what's
allowed if the patient does consent it's
not allowed thank you very much
representative profile did you have your
hand up
I did thank you Mr chairman so I guess I
would just point out that genetic
um
genetic information by its very nature
cannot be
de-identified unless you start to break
down a patient's Gene sequence and only
share parts of it so
um there are
privacy implications associated with
sharing genetic data that perhaps don't
apply to other forms of of information
um
um I guess in in an Ideal World I would
like to see a a kind of uh consent
reversal process similar to what Europe
has instituted with GPR having said that
um I don't think we're going to solve
that problem today
um I'm I'm in agreement with
representative Weber that you know there
is a there is there is a consent form it
is in control of the patient they have
the the responsibility to read that and
the right to decide whether or not to
share that information
representative Murphy well thank you and
I will you know I will vote um in favor
of this amendment because I believe in
its intent
um I have been involved in meta-analysis
studies before I appreciate the value
and the power of data uh that is
collected in large numbers
um I I was just trying to make sure that
we all understand that the consent is
patient driven and not taken away from
them in any shape or form uh in anything
that's currently written in statute so
thank you thank you another discussion
representative Weber
that was that was very much what we were
trying to restore
another discussion
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
a roll the motion is
ought to pass on Amendment 1954 h
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Coco yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Pearson yes
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes representative
Cannon yes
representative Lane yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Lloyd
representative Tellez yes
and represent McDonald yes
unanimous 20-0
okay very good
do I have another motion
does anyone want to a representative
American he also make a motion to ought
to pass as amended on Senate bill 240.
is there a second
representative Murphy seconds
any discussion on the motion
representative Weber
I think we for my purposes we've
discussed it plenty but I would uh
request that the drafter of the report
make it very clear in specific language
that it is the intent of
that the intent of the bill is to ensure
the maximum amount of control for a
patient over their medical decisions and
uh you know I can't draft it in my head
like that but I if if we have a
statement about intent in the blurb it
will it will be helpful to bankrupt so
ever I would more than glad to share
that with anyone else on the committee
to help me draft it correctly because
I'd be glad to consult yet you're
drafting it the representative
merchandise so I'll be drafting it yes
and anyone else in the committee wishes
to help uh by all means let me know I'll
send it off to you as well
question to the chair when does this
have to be and by
um I always the sooner the better but
the house isn't meeting until June 8th
so it needs to be do we have some time
yeah okay not meeting house is not
meeting next week so
the discussion
okay the motion is ought to pass on as
octopass is amended on Senate bill 240.
well that's Clark to call the roll
thank you
representative land yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Pearson yes
representative pelosa yes
this is representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Canada yes representative
Blaine yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Lloyd yes
representative tayos yes
and represent McDonald's yes
20-0
there's no objection we'll put that on
the consent calendar
okay that is the only Bill we had for
executive session
uh if it's in order and I believe it is
we could revisit
um
House Bill 238
close out the executive session and
return the house bill 238 and we do have
we did have uh we saved some valuable
information during the break and
um
I believe it would be an order to ask
perhaps that they come forward and yeah
that representative Weber
so would you like to come up and share
what
your insights on this however
I'm sure
but feel free to grab another chair and
and please identify yourselves and make
sure the microphone is on
thank you Mr chair my name is Alex
katrubis I'm a registered lobbyist for
the area agencies the 10 area agencies
that provide and coordinate services for
people with developmental disabilities
hi good morning I'm Stephanie Patrick
and I'm the chair of the quality Council
and also the executive director of
disability rights Center
I just want to say on you know on behalf
of the area agencies we feel that
there was obviously a lot of discussion
in this committee on this legislation
when it came over to the Senate
exactly House Bill 238 relative to the
uh quality Council developmental
Services quality Council you may recall
at the hearing there was a lot of
concern that families and Advocates and
providers didn't feel included in a lot
of the decisions that were made by the
department and so this bill was clearly
a result of that concern out in the
community around the state so
representative McMahon who has long been
a champion of Developmental services in
the state brought forward this
legislation and the air agencies did
support it when it came over to the
Senate there was a lot of concern just
for your information this this
legislation did not go to the Health and
Human Services Committee in the Senate
it actually went to the executive
departments and administration the Edna
committee largely because of the the
Contracting components that were in the
legislation and there was a lot of
concern particularly by uh some of the
leadership on the committee that uh
because of the the procurement rules and
legal issues around fairness in terms of
how State contracts are awarded that um
they were not comfortable with a lot of
the language that was in the building
you might recall that you actually
scaled back some of that language as
well in terms of how it was introduced
so we had an initial amendment that was
uh presented largely written by the
department and the area agencies and and
the DRC and other Advocates did push
back on that Amendment because I I
personally felt that it was sort of a
toothless tiger that was not not a lot
of meaningful change that was part of
that Amendment we went back to the
drawing board came up with I think a
good amendment that requires uh at a
minimum quarterly dialogue between the
council and the department the
department has to respond in writing and
there's a lot of detailed uh information
that they can't just uh respond with you
know one sentence it has to be in
writing there has to be uh detailed
explanations about why they're making
the decisions that they are so I think
that this bill just to summarize uh is
going to improve communication between
the developmental disability Community
the providers the families uh and and
The Advocates like like the DRC so I I
guess just to summarize not to speak for
others but the department the the
providers and groups like the disability
rights Center which are advocacy
organizations that don't provide
services but represent individuals and
families in the system to make sure that
they're treated fairly and receive the
services that they need all of the
groups were able to come together after
a couple of uh additional amendments in
the Senate to come to a conclusion that
we were all able to support this bill so
I think it's probably three quarters of
a loaf and we're just concerned that if
you ask for a committee a conference I
don't know how much more the Senate
would give on this so it's probably best
to take the three quarters of the loaf
and and not risk this bill being
defeated or even the Senate may be
non-concurrent because I don't think
there's going to be a lot of
appetite to go to go back to the
Contracting issues I think there there
are some concerns there so we don't want
to risk a lot of the good work that was
done so I'll turn it over to um the DRC
unless there's other questions
foreign
thank you yep so I just wanted to be
clear the quali one of the things that
this bill addresses is that some
problems that quality Council has had
with making sure that people with
disabilities and family members can
participate in the council
um we faced that issue last week at the
scheduled quality council meeting so
we're not able to hold an official
meeting so we did not we did not take an
official vote on the position on this
bill and so I can't speak for the
quality Council as a whole as in terms
of disability rights Center I agree with
Alex
um I think that it while there is still
room to improve the process this bill as
it stands as amended by the Senate does
put us in a much better place to be able
to address the concerns the quality
Council had you know I've talked to
representative McMahon and he's very
open to additional legislation if that's
needed if this process isn't working in
a couple of years or at least he was
when I talked to him a couple of weeks
ago and so I agree I I think as as
representative DRC and a member of the
quality Council I would say that this is
a good comprehend that address some of
the concerns the department raised and
I'm equally as concerned as Alex that we
will run into problems getting it back
through the Senate if it changes much
okay questions representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um
I think both of you coming would kind of
sway my vote on this but I'll just ask
um since so much of the discussion that
happened in our initial hearing involve
the Consultants that were hired and do
did do a report and um and that people
in the disabilities Community felt like
they were not
consulted and did not have a say in that
um
so what I'm hearing you say that you
that there are other good things in this
bill and you're well willing to let go
of the involvement in the Contracting
process in the future
I think so I mean I think that you know
the the bill sets up in process so that
we have quarterly dialogues with the
department and so I think if if a
contract that the department was
considering or that they had implemented
was part of the concerns of the quality
Council there's no restriction on
putting that into that letter and then
invoking this process that's outlined to
have conversations with it in that way
at least I mean I think you know
originally the council members really
wanted to be more of a a voice during
that process
I think that would be ideal but I do
think that there would be a way to have
those kinds of conversations either in
writing or at quality Council meetings
even about contracts
um you know just be a little bit
different it may be a little slower
thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman um I'm trying to
look at this it seems like there are
changes Beyond just the Contracting so
there are other changes that are
happening if it
I guess I I frankly would be
disappointed if there were concerns
about places beyond the Contracting and
the Senate wouldn't come to the table if
we were willing to budge on the
Contracting issue but still had other
concerns for these differences so um
is that something where where are the
other changes have been meaningful or
those ones that you're just willing to
accede to
I guess you're willing to accede to all
of it so I guess that's not a question I
mean I I think that the the process is
much more detailed than it was in terms
of feedback from the council you know
there um now there's a limit of
quarterly to invoke this process that
you can see outlined in the Senate
version of the bill
um in terms of you know we didn't
outline it just that if the council
sends a letter to the department
um with concerns the department has to
respond in writing within 30 days and
now there's a process of coming to a
meeting and having a discussion
um
I think
I think we'll have to see if that is
better it's definitely more detailed
than it was in the house version
um you know I think that generally
conversations are more productive
sometimes than letters back and forth
um to really make sure that the concerns
if are being addressed we've seen that
in the I've seen that in the quality
council's comments on roles now that we
have a member of the department who sits
in on the rules committee meetings where
we go over the kind of detailed concerns
about that I think it's made the conver
the Department's understanding of the
quality council is concerned richer
um you know I like I said I mean if it's
if we're running up against a limit and
frustrations that once a quarter is not
sufficient I think we could revisit that
in the future I mean last year we sent
them four four formal letters with
concerns um
so if following that track I think we
would be okay
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
would you believe that after the last
discussion on this legislation I was
very disturbed
by a long-standing concern
about protecting the DD population
so I went ahead and
formulated a request to the
oversight Committee of Health and Human
Services
whose our former chair and present chair
of the oversight committee has that
application
I'm I'm convinced because I know
a few people very well
that you're content with what has
resulted
so I don't think we need to proceed with
the oversight committee
but that opportunity is there
and it's a opportunity I think that
works extremely well the chairman
actually has chaired two of those
subcommittees himself
so that opportunity is there but I would
consider that we are now withdrawing
that request
thank you representative Weber
here's one of the things that's my
concern
um in Roman numeral four I was looking
at the language you said you know they
were going to meet quarterly but the
language actually says uh
now I've lost it again
um
it says no more frequently than no more
frequently than quarterly so
the concern that that raises for me I
was thought when you were outlining it
that we were talking about a at a
minimum quarterly as opposed to no more
frequently than quarterly my concern
with this language and you know we we
can certainly I I'm perfectly willing to
let go of the
Contracting stuff I understand what the
problems are of that but if you agree to
saying you're going to raise your
concerns no more frequently than
quarterly if you've just had your
quarterly meeting and something comes up
the next week that is terribly
concerning to
the community
you have foreclosed any opportunity to
do anything about it for another three
months
so
that is a real concern to me and I see
represent I see that Mr Williams is
making faces in the back there so
perhaps he disagrees with me but there's
only one way I can read the words no
more frequently than quarterly it means
no more frequently than quarterly and
that is of concern to me and I wonder if
it's of concern to you as well
representative Pearson thank you Mr
chairman no more frequently than
quarterly officially
but I do think the department knows from
all of the activity we've been doing
that we want to keep ongoing
conversations and I think nothing here
would preclude an informal Chit Chat
certainly nothing would preclude us
coming back with more next year if that
was necessary or nothing would preclude
us firing up the subcommittee
representative McKay had brought at one
point I don't think that no more than
quarterly shuts off all discussion back
and forth
so right now they don't have to respond
the quarterly limit is really about
their responding to what the quality
council is is asking or raising as a
concern right now they don't have to
respond at all
right nothing that required so at least
this gives us quarterly
uh you know meaty I call it Media or
meaningful feedback from the Department
that they can't just ignore and say that
they didn't get the letter not that
that's really happening but I I've heard
that it that it could be happening you
know that they don't feel that they're
getting a a meaningful dialogue so this
this requires quarterly feedback and
meaningful dialogue and in addition to
that the bill that's amended by the
Senate if you look at Roman five there
are exceptions uh for administrative
rules regulations proposals or other
initiatives impacting quality so those
issues would not be subject to the
quarterly limit and that was put in um
as a request of uh Stephanie Patrick in
the Senate and they were that was
actually the third amendment in
committee that they considered because
exactly the point that you're raising
representative Weber so I think I want
to speak for Stephanie but I think that
gives her a little more comfort that uh
many of the issues that are talked about
on a regular basis will not be subject
to the quarterly limitation I'm I I
didn't see that because
so I would that gives me a certain
amount more Comfort my concern was when
you say no more frequently than
quarterly
um
I I am
in entirely agreement with
representative Pearson about the
informal Communications
um and but
first of all informal communication
certainly didn't seem to work before and
um
while we have Earnest representations
from the Department that they want to do
better
changes could happen in the department
so I like having it in statute
pointing out the provisions in
Roman 5 make me feel considerably more
comfortable with the quarterly
restriction so
I guess I've been talked around to being
willing if it's the will of the
committee to change my position on
requesting a committee of conference
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I guess my question is if um if
the council comments on those changes
and rules regulation proposals or other
initiatives is the department with the
requirement Department how to written
response is there any requests that the
department would respond with a written
response or perhaps would that be that
last last inch that we need to reach
agreement
because that doesn't seem to me that
they can comment but there doesn't need
to be a response I guess I'm curious if
there's any follow-up there I mean they
do have as Stephanie said they do have a
representative on the council so
hopefully there would be dialogue there
uh and you know as representative Weber
said you know the intention is that they
hopefully through this process they've
come to the understanding that uh there
was a problem here and that they will be
more responsive but you're right
representative there's I guess you're
right the way I read it there's no
necessarily requirement that they
provide a formal written response under
Roman five uh you know the same way that
they would have to under the quarterly
requirement
I I guess as a follow-up to that I I'll
back off on most of it but I still would
want to see a committee of conference
even if it's just adding that line to
and request a written response and
backing off on the rest a lot of the
rest of it
representative
hi thank you um I just have a wondering
uh because to me no more than quarterly
means
never once a year like what where is
there a minimum or a specified required
frequency of a meeting
I think I don't think there is a minimum
I mean I think that would be at the will
of the council you know the council that
would give the council the ability to
invoke this process as it's outlined as
it seats fit which I think is what we
thought that that was the intention so
the council would
send in my understanding of the process
the council would discuss an issue at a
meeting and develop a letter that
reflects the council's concerns on
whatever it is it could be we do this
once a quarter and we capture everything
that we've been worried about over that
quarter or we we well the council will
have to decide how it would manage that
we'd send the letter we would make it
clear that we're invoking the process
that's outlined in that in section four
and then then we would we would invoke
it then I mean I
there may be times when the council does
not feel the need to invoke the formal
process because the conversations have
been productive enough we want to
require us to do that or require the
department to do that if it wasn't
needed
another discussion
Mr chair uh yes representative Bertrand
thank you I want to follow up on to the
comments one is in regards to the
frequency in which things are meeting if
you will I understand the issue seems to
be communication between the agencies
and the department but who is calling
these meetings is it the department or
the agencies themselves because I'm
concerned about it the Department's
calling it and they only have to do it
no more than quarterly that they could
do it six months there's nothing in here
zero
which following up exactly to your point
and the number two I do have a concern
if you go back and look on page four
it goes back to the frequency of the
meetings
if you submit something's recommendation
and then the department sends back a
response saying well geez we didn't have
time to get to it for all these reasons
he meeting every quarterly that's a
six-month time frame
so if we're really trying to act on
things as recommendations from the
council
where is there anything in the statute
that requires a the frequency of the
meetings and B that there's some action
taken at some point in time and actually
keep kicking the can down the road
so as the as exists in the another part
of the legislation the changes that you
saw the the chair of the council the
vice chair the the
um commissioner or his or her designee
can call meetings of the council we
traditionally meet monthly
um although we occasionally can meet on
an emergency basis
um in addition to that but we have a
standing monthly meeting
it's down at the bottom
representative Pearson thank you Mr
chairman
um
as some of you know I've been behind the
scenes on this for quite a while
and let me just say I am very encouraged
by the Department's response we're not
at the finish line yet but not only are
we not where we were we're moving in the
right direction and I don't see
the department being
indifferent or hostile and if they are
we can always have another bill or we
can crank up a subcommittee I give I'd
take the win and I'd give them a
compliment
representative Merchant
a sort of digressing for a second but we
also have a retain Bill 603 I'm sorry
608 which deals with a pilot is that an
opportunity for us to dive deeper into
the Contracting side of the equation
during that subcommittee and the retain
bill so we can break them apart once
dealing with communication one's dealing
with Contracting we can get the
communication part so it's going forward
but still have a way in a vehicle to
talk about the Contracting side yeah
yeah of course thank you you can take my
seat please we need a bigger table
sure sure are a smaller uh legislative
director so
um there is already in existence a state
procurement committee and I would
suggest that if you are studying the
issue of procurement it should go
through that already established
committee
I do understand also that house bill 608
was retained specifically for the
purpose as a vehicle for additional
legislation be it whatever it might be
also the department has honored although
not part of a legislative proposal a
monthly or on every single regular
meeting of the HHS oversight to
providing an update uh to to that
committee
representative Weber
I just note that if we were going to
draft that kind of an amendment to 608
it would need to be the subject of a a
non-germane
a non-germaine Amendment hearing because
it's not close enough to the original
intent there but we've got plenty of
time to do that if we needed to do it
other questions for these folks
okay
I think as well as that thank you thank
you for the opportunity thank you
thank you for the information
well having heard all of that is there
still opposition then To None concur or
what would we like to do
I've heard generally still none
representative Weber
I having
am willing willing to back off on
non-concur and request a committee of
conference but I I would love to hear
how other committee members feel about
it because I can I can certainly see
I can certainly see reasons for going
either way and I I do concur with
representative Leon's concerns
so I think the question is whether we
proceed with the half a low for three
quarters of a loaf and then
um perhaps do some more work get this
part
what I see is helpful is maybe getting
this part into statute and then taking
advantage of uh retained Bill 608 if we
need to make further changes
those changes will be acted on in
January and go over to the Senate and
you know there will be a whole nother
round of negotiations or or
non-negotiations but at least we would
have this much in the statute and that
would be I think a step in the right
direction
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman while I understand and agree
with some of the um
lack of clarity about the number of
meetings and um and those kinds of
things and concerned about taking the
Contracting part out I think the intent
of the people who brought this
legislation
was to give the disabilities Community a
bigger voice and I think
um you know certainly there were only
two people here sitting at the table so
they don't represent everybody in the
disabilities Community but they came and
they um used their voice to say we don't
want to lose this so I would tend to go
along with
um their requests that we concur on this
so that would be my vote thank you
representative Merchant
I concur
um with representative Weber
it's better probably to have
a partial of the no loaf this does start
the process of communication between the
two entities
and given the fact that retained Bill
608 is probably not going to work its
way through the calendar until sometime
in March of next year we'll have time to
see how this actually works if we're
sensing or hearing that the
communication process which is this is
designed to do is in fact not working
the way we think it should work we can
always address it try to look at it from
House Bill 608 and try to refine it at
that point in time or
so that my take on would be to concur
take what we have get the process
started see how it works it was off time
if we need to to react to it thank you
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman uh I agree at this
point uh to concur
I do with some interpretation
based on years of difficulty
I'm
more comfortable with perceiving since
at least I put a document in that will
work if it doesn't
if we don't get the results that we see
the fact that I've withdrew it it
doesn't mean that it's withdrawn from
potential
use that the chairman and I have talked
about this I did not accept your
withdrawal yeah
yeah so that I agree with that with the
understanding that if we continue to
have difficulties of communication that
there is a opportunity to resolve that
now right now
thank you representative Plaza
I agree with concerns around Contracting
but I think we want this bill Senate
wants this bill I don't see a risk and
negotiation
negotiating especially that we are
already
for some reasonable Senate amendments so
I want to stick with our previous
decision for committee of confidence
thank you rectum Murphy
thank you Mr chairman I am
I I would
um
agree with the concerns of in the
trepidation is that representative McKay
and Leon have about you know the timing
and the structure Etc but on the other
hand when I have the people that are
most directly impacted by the
legislation accepting three quarters of
a loaf understanding that we have
safeguards in place whether it be 608 or
representative McKay's you know ability
to communicate with the oversight
committee I I I hate to in in regards to
representative web is concerned about
getting to Committee of conference and
having somehow just be sabotaged beyond
the intent of this committee I would
frankly go along with concurrence and
with the appropriate safeguards in place
feel very comfortable in doing that
without going to Committee of conference
thank you
other thoughts representative
uh yes I think we've heard from the very
people affected by this that they would
be happy if we concur
um I think we should not this is one of
those cases where we should not let the
perfect be the enemy of the good
um so I think a simple concurs in order
thank you other thoughts representative
Leon
um thank you Mr chairman it seems that
the overwhelming Viewpoint is to do this
um I guess the one asked I would have
would be that perhaps I can speak to
those um on the other side see if they
would agree about the idea of the
request for a written response if there
is a full support of that last little
closing the Gap fantastic if not I'm
good with concurring so I don't know if
uh if I could have a little bit of time
just to see if they'd agree to request
that written response or if that would
then lose the support of this committee
representative Weber
I'd be glad to co-sponsor a bill to that
effect next time around
I appreciate that support um my biggest
concern is just how many changes are
going on so um I I guess I'll stay stay
quiet for now we'll work towards that
bill next year and um
I'll let you know if I hear anything
okay any other thoughts any other
discussion
oh okay
well I mean again but I'm here primarily
hearing too is to Concur and forget
about the committee of conference uh
representative Leon if you get new
information I'm certainly happy to
consider it but that would be the
recommendation it seems like we're
headed in right now so and again the
house will not be meeting until June 8th
so we do have some time to find out
okay I know of no other business to come
before us this morning or today it's
afternoon now
um so I will uh adjourn and uh given
what we have pending we will adjourn at
the call of the chair